a single most important feature for many
apps is the user authentication system
if you don't have a good way to sign-in
users and observe their data it's hard
to build out anything else in today's
video we'll implement Google OAuth via
firebase in an angular app in addition
we'll save custom information about the
user in the firestore database and we'll
implement full stack security on both
the front end and the back end so by the
end of this video you should have a
solid off system that you can build on
if you're new here like and subscribe
and you can find the full source code on
fire ship io and I'd like to quickly
point out that this is the first episode
with the new fire ship io channel name
but this video is actually a revision of
episode 55 from angular firebase over
the next few months I'll be revising and
updating a lot of that content so if
there's anything you want to see me
revisit let me know in the comments to
get started with this lesson you'll need
to have an angular app with angular fire
and firebase installed you can find full
instructions for that on the main lesson
page first we'll go into our firebase
project and under the authentication tab
we'll enable the Google sign-in method
from there we'll go ahead and enable
fire store and for now we'll leave the
security rules unlocked but we'll circle
back around to this at the end of the
video to secure the backend when we sign
in a user with firebase it's going to
create this authentication record but
it's very limited and we can't easily
customize it the important thing that it
gives us is a unique user ID which we
can use to model relational data in fire
store for example you might have a has
one relationship where a user has an
account and we can easily model that in
the database by just giving the document
itself the same user ID as the
authentication record now we'll jump
into angular and write some code that
can read write and react to this data in
real time your user authentication logic
and state is something that you'll be
managing globally so you'll want to have
it organized as an angular service so we
can go ahead and generate it with the
angular CLI by running ng generate
service and I'm putting it inside of a
services directory now before we get
into the service itself there's one
optional thing you can do here and
that's model your data as a typescript
interface if you have a lot of complex
custom data on the user document it
helps to be very explicit about it so
every property that can exist on the
user document will also exist on this
type
scrip interface preventing bugs that
send invalid data to the database now we
can jump into our off service and we'll
start by importing a few things first
well use the angular router to redirect
users after they sign out then
angularfire provides us with services
that we can use to interact with
firebase auth and fire store and lastly
we have a couple of things here from
rxjs that we'll use for the control flow
on the user autumn servable and
optionally you can also import the user
interface that we defined in the last
step the service has one piece of
stateful data that we can share between
all of our components and that is the
database record itself the user document
it's defined as an observable because it
can change in real time for example when
the user signs in or signs out right now
you'll see that it's typed to any but if
you're using the user interface you'll
want to type it to the user the next
thing we'll do is inject our
dependencies in the constructor so we
have angularfire auth firestore and the
router now we'll want to define our
actual user observable as soon as
possible which would be in the
constructor of this service so we'll
start by making it equal to the angular
fire off state and if you're not using
any custom data you can just stop right
there because that'll give you the user
record that you have in the
authentication tab but in most cases
you're going to want more data than that
so we'll use the off state to switch to
an observable of this database record we
can do this with the rxjs which map
operator which allows us to listen to
the user that's emitted from this off
state observable and then switch to a
different observable of the database
record so we'll have access to the user
inside of switch map which is either
going to be the user authentication
record or null so if the user is defined
then we'll go ahead and reach out to
fire store by calling AFS doc and then
point to the document with the matching
user ID and lastly we call value changes
to convert it to an observable if the
user is not defined then we just want to
return an observable of null from switch
map this could be some kind of other
default value but it allows us to tell
when the user is not logged in so now we
have a user record in fire store that we
can react to based on the authentication
state but in order for this to be useful
we need a way for the user to first log
in so I'll create an async function here
called Google sign-in because most of
the firebase API is actually promise
based so we make a reference to the
Google auth provider
and then we pass that in to sign in with
pop up and that will trigger the actual
pop-up modal where the user logs in to
their Google account that's going to
resolve with the credential of that user
which we can then use to update user
data in fire store we'll implement this
method next but I'd like to point out
that you can also update or create the
user record and fire store with a cloud
function we're not going to cover it in
this video but just know that that's an
option the next thing we'll do is really
quickly implement a sign out method this
will also be an async function and it
will just await the angularfire
off sign out and then navigate back to
the root page so currently this update
user data method is just taking
information from the angular fired off
state and then marrying it on the
firestore document but this is the point
where you could add any kind of custom
data that you want so we'll take the
user from the credential that we get
after the pop-up sign in and we'll point
to the document in the database with
that user ID from there we'll define
that data payload that we want to save
then we'll call set on the user
reference and pass at this data when you
call set its destructive so if there's
an existing document in this place it
will erase all that data and replace it
that's usually not the behavior that you
want for a returning user so you can
avoid it by adding this merge true
option which will only change the
properties that change in the data
payload in other words the existing data
will not be erased if you want to get a
little fancy with your JavaScript you
could actually destructor all these
properties in the function argument
basically we're just taking the
properties on the object and
automatically assigning them as
variables inside the scope of this
function and thank you typescript for
telling me exactly what's wrong as I
refactor that takes care of all the hard
stuff now we can go into any component
and just inject this off service in the
constructor and share its data and
functionality
I want to bind this to the HTML so I'm
making it a public property and the
constructor now we can switch over to
the HTML and just write some logic using
angular's directives our user is an
observable which means we need to
subscribe to it in angular we can do
this with the async pipe which will
automatically manage the subscription
for us and we can write as user which
sets a template variable for the user
document information that we can use
directly here in the template and if
that value happens to be null then we're
going to display a login button for
debugging purposes we'll use the JSON
pipe
you show the user object directly in the
view and this is only available to the
logged in user so we'll also add a sign
out button here as well and that's as
simple as binding to the click event and
then calling off sign out the next thing
we'll do is define that login template
which we can do with an NG template tag
and give it a name of login then we
create another button inside of here and
this time buying the click event to off
Google sign-in now we can finally check
out our app in the browser and you'll
see if we click the log in with Google
button we should get this pop-up window
and once we sign in it will show the
user information in the view
automatically now at this point having a
couple of extra tips for you if you're
using angular material you'll want to
check out the ngx off firebase UI
library which has a bunch of pre-built
components that can help you get things
done faster another thing you might
notice is that this JSON user object is
really hard to read another little pro
tip that comes from be man on Twitter is
to wrap your JSON pipe and a pre tag it
will put every object property on its
own line which is much easier to read
especially if you have a big object so
now we have a working user
authentication system in place but now
you'll probably want to define some
routes that can only be accessed by a
logged in user for example the user
dashboard angular provides a really
elegant solution to composing your
router logic first I'm going to define a
component called super secret that
should only be accessed by logged in
users and then I'll add it to the secret
route in the router config now back in
the app you can see that we're not
logged in and if we click the secret
button it still navigates to the secret
route we're going to generate another
thing called a guard which is actually
just an angular service that has some
special methods that we can implement to
control the router logic the most common
one is can activate which is a method
that will return a boolean or an
observable of a boolean and if it's true
it will activate the route if it's false
it will not we already have the user
observable from our off service it's
just not in a boolean format yet so we
can go ahead and inject the off service
in the guard constructor then we'll
return the user observable from the can
activate method but we'll need to first
pipe in a few rxjs operators the first
one is take 1 which will automatically
complete the observable after the first
value is emitted because we don't need
to keep it running after the route has
been blocked then we'll use map
to map the object to a boolean and we
can do that with just a double bang
because we have an observable of null if
the users not logged in and lastly if
the users not logged in you probably
want to navigate them to a login page or
somewhere else in our case we'll just go
ahead and console.log access tonight so
that's all there is to it and now we can
use this on any route that requires this
logic we can tell angular where to apply
it by going back to our router and then
using the can activate property and
adding it to the array now if we go back
to the app and try to navigate to this
route it's going to console.log access
denied but more importantly it's not
going to instantiate that component so
that gives us some front-end logic for
the user experience but it doesn't give
us full stack security someone could
still grab our firebase credentials and
modify other user records those
credentials have to be in the
client-side code so in order to secure
the app we need a rule that will only
allow authenticated users to modify
documents with the corresponding user ID
so we'll go down here to the users path
and then add a wildcard for the user ID
and we'll say awhile right
if the is owner function resolves to
true it's optional to write this as a
function and fire store but I like to
write my rules as functions because they
tend to be a lot more readable
especially when you have a lot of
complex document relationships so we can
easily implement this by saying request
auth UID equals the wildcard user ID in
other words if you're not logged in to
the correct account you can't read or
write the user document now one thing
you have to be careful of is with
firebase rules it's going to look for
the first rule currently our rules will
not work because we're still allowing
reads and writes at the global level
firebase will see that first and allow
the operation so I recommend doing if
false at the global level just so
everything is locked down by default so
now we have a fully secure angular
firebase authentication system it can
scale the millions of users it reacts to
changes in real time and it can handle
any kind of custom data we want to throw
at it I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there but I'm considering doing this
same video with other frameworks like
maybe you react view and flutter just so
you can compare the differences at a
very fundamental and practical level if
you want to see that happen let me know
in the comments so I can prioritize it
thanks for watching and I
I'll talk to you soon
[Music]